m
un accueil exceptionnel pour une
personne non moins exceptionnel
lorsqu'on la voit arriver amélie ne
laisse pas deviner son âge et pourtant
cette coquette dame au sourire ravageur
et plein d'humanité a vu défiler devant
ses yeux plus d'un siècle d'histoire
je suis contente de vous avoir un élu
les à david est né le 2 octobre 1916
notre centenaire coule des jours heureux
désormais dans les hauts de la
possession à dos d'âne où elle vit avec
cette fille et vous vivez ici avec avec
si bien à l'oral à l'habitat des tâches
est mort mais aménagé tout ici un pas
pour moi super regarder quand c'est beau
c'est le bonheur la vienne face à la
montagne à la mer
yala géniaux réunis sous vos yeux la
gent vraiment une magnifique 104 enfants
sans gardien petit l'enfant amélie à
david a voulu tous les réunir pour cet
anniversaire spécial fier d'abord de
vivre un tel événement en suisse que
c'est sa propre nom c'est très émouvant
moi je suis de métropole exprès pour
l'événement donc c'est vraiment fort
fort fort mais on a déjà beaucoup fait
et on a déjà fait deux de grandes fêtes
et on attend une troisième le réseau la
fabrica les états unis dix enfants et
des petits enfants très fiers de leur
mamie c'est sans doute cet amour qui
permet à amélie de continuer à rester
toujours passionné de cette vie remplie
de sérénité très très fier très fier
d'avoir une grand-mère de cent ans dans
une forme pareil havre il ya quand même
toute sa tête et qui est qui rigolent
bien non c'est un vrai bonheur après
avoir passé sa vie à madagascar où ses
parents ont fait toute leur carrière
professionnelle
amélie a vécu en métropole je suis née
arden arrive on est parti en france
j'ai cherché à travailler en france j'en
ai cinq ans la conseillère
départementale à une flore de vaud a
tenu à partager ce moment avec un
millier sa famille liot front de la part
de tous les élus yeux de la prison du
département les fleurs du chocolat et en
cadeau sur actifs vraiment c'est
vraiment ce qu'il fallait là c'est très
très gentil aurélien de mémoire on ne
peut pas faire mieux
tout va me revenir je trouve que c'est
assez primordiale à la réunion on a
gardé malgré tout cette valeur de garder
nos
nos personnes âgées chez nous le maximum
de temps on n'en serait pas là la
réunion n'en serait pas là s'il n'y
avait pas eu le travail de nos anciens
et aujourd'hui il est temps de leur
donner du bon temps il est temps de
prendre le temps pour eux la recette de
longévité d'amélie c'est avant tout de
profiter des siens de la vie de la
nature de cette nature qu'elle admire
chaque matin la douceur de vivre à la
créole les valeurs familiales c'est tout
simplement cela des petits bonheurs
d'amérique